hello youtube i'm ian bremmer and
talking about whether or not Obama is
going to make a difference for the
better in 2009 i'm just certainly is
going to make a difference for the worse
but the question is how much he can
really do no one here in the World
Economic Forum really thinks that the
economy has been improved significantly
before 2010 so there are limitations
there and and secondly there's a
question of just how much time and
effort the Obama administration is going
to be able to actually put outside the
United States and I'm sitting here at
Davos I was actually asked the other day
on CNBC about whether i was sad that
there weren't any Americans who I said
well I'm an American I should we make
happy what they're talking about the
Obama administration in fact they're
just know foreign policy officials the
Obama administration is going to be
focused almost exclusively on dealing
with the domestic economy and that
that's the reason why Gates was
reappointed as Secretary of Defense it's
you know you have a lot of great special
envoys with a lot of experience at the
end of the day you really want to make
it better the president would have to
spend an awful lot of time on the ground
on the road and in 2009 I don't expect
that's going to happen so a long term I
think there's going to be a honeymoon
Obama is going to be more multilateral
in form and in content we already saw an
al-jazeera that he's reaching out to
moderate Islamic communities around the
world I thought that was very effective
this is a guy who's going to ask the
Europeans for more troops in Afghanistan
will probably have some success there I
think the world is generally rooting for
Obama with a very few exceptions but in
2009 do I think he's going to make a
fundamental and structural difference
the world unbalanced no thanks